hallo meine lieben mein traum war es
schon immer ein eigenheim für meine
familie zu bauen
eine küche in der ich meine videos
drehen und rezepte entwickeln kann ein
ort an welchem ich mit meinen eltern
zusammen wohnen weil es mir einfach auch
wichtig ist dass meine kinder mit oma
und opa groß werden
meine mitarbeiter sind meine freunde und
mit ihnen arbeiten wir bei uns zu hause
jeder hat sein eigenes aufgabengebiet es
werden videos geschnitten grafiken
entwickelt produkte entworfen bücher
erstellt möbel und messestände gebaut
deutscher self videos gedreht und vieles
vieles mehr
wir haben einen ort erschaffen an dem
wir uns alle wohl fühlen
samira und ella sind jetzt alt genug und
möchten gerne wissen wie alles mit
unserem haus angefangen hat samira el a
wir erzählen euch heute wie und warum
wir unser haus gebaut haben kommt setzt
euch mal hin
[Musik]
sind sie schon auch wichtig dass ich
aussehe wie ein spanischer personal
trainer
wir haben claudia kroll kubin
wassermelonen verkäufer so michaela
setzt sich michael sind wohl nicht was
erzählen ihr fragt er immer wie das bei
uns waren so mit dem hausbau und heute
erzählen wir euch bauen wir uns
überhaupt für ein smartphone entschieden
haben ja eine geschichte eine geschichte
momentan ist es total im trend jeder der
ein haus baut oder sein haus
modernisiert beschäftigt sich ja echt
mit dem thema smart home und sie haben
es ja auch schon relativ früh gemacht
genau da gibt es sehr verschiedene
anbieter es gibt verschiedene systeme
und manchmal sieht man den wald vor
lauter wollen nicht richtig richtig
gemacht
und wenn man es auch schon auf messen
umgeschaut werden auch im freundeskreis
schon gefragt und wir haben dann auch
einen arzt kennen gelernt der das ganze
uns erklärt hat wir waren bei ihm im
haus und haben uns das angeschaut aber
ich muss echt sagen es war uns zu
technisch na ja und zwar ganz süße nasa
zu uns gesagt man will erklärt sich so
wie es wünschenswert oder wiener zitiert
ja er hat leider wenig erklärt dass man
ja viel zu technisch genau wir haben es
nicht verstanden weil japaner fällt
morgen nicht mal geschafft das
spülmaschinen salz auf das gefühl wie
soll dann verstehen wir in versuchung zu
führen oder wer das programmieren kann
genau und in der finanzbranche zieht und
zwar versteht damit die kinder wissen
nicht was eine finanz branche
das machen wir alles auf jeden tag ein
bisschen nichts wovon du nicht verstehst
heißt es ich immer mache ich nur wüsste
wovon du ahnung hast genau genommen und
haben wirklich lange überlegt und dann
haben uns doch für ein smartphone
entschieden
aber wie es dann dazu führen dass
erzählen wir euch später ich meine man
muss sich halt immer überlegen macht es
überhaupt sinn macht ein smart home bei
mir zu hause sind macht sinn dass mir
meine kaffeemaschine zum beispiel am
ende des jahres sagt wie viel latte
macchiato cappuccino oder wie viel es
plätschert getrunken habe man ändert
sich dadurch etwas an meinem
verbraucherverhalten werden jeden tag in
den nachrichten zugeballert das war bei
uns in juden nicht so
und wer bekommt werbebotschaften
nachrichten an und dran und ich möchte
nicht wissen was man kaffee ich
getrunken habe ich den prozent
cappuccino und es interessiert mich
einfach nicht stell dir mal vor der
kaffeemaschine und dann sitzt du gerade
auf dem sofa und dies ganz gemütlich und
da so plötzlich lust auf dem kaffee mit
dem handy hoch startet die app man kann
ja einfach schön café rauslassen ja
bringt aber wenig gemacht ich glaube
dass er druck stehst bringt aber wenig
wenn wir das noch unterstellen muss
deswegen ist es wenig sinnvoll und
momentan ist wirklich so jeder versuch
irgendwie smart zu sein
und da fehlt einfach die sinnhaftigkeit
man muss damit ich auch mal hin hohe
fragen wer bin ich was machen und es
musste einfach die arbeit abnehmen und
ich möchte nicht ständig auf meinem
handy schauen müssen sind die rollläden
alle zu- oder wie kann ich das licht im
wohnzimmer steuern wie kommt der mann
die tür ein
ich meine er kennt den papa er hat
bisher alle haustürschlüssel verloren
werden und wir brauchen einfach ein
system was uns die haustürschlüssel
was hat überflüssig man doch lustig
macht und jetzt zählt zum beispiel auf
dem handy
mein akku leer also meine akkus tut und
was passiert jetzt mit onkel japan
telefonieren ja jetzt kann ich kann
immer stärker nicht steuern und deswegen
wollte ich wollte nie ein smartphone
haben wo wir 1 0 im handy steuern
zumal ihr beiden ja noch kein handy habt
das heißt die kinder müssen ja auch im
smart home zurechtkommen und die haben
noch keine handy oder überhaupt keins
bekommen soll
ich hab erst als 16 gekriegt ja doch
damals am strand lag einmal mehr ist
gerade gespielt genau das war's das war
letztes jahr überhaupt dann schrank
gespielt da habe ich mich wie jemand
über smart home unterhalten
und da scheint mir stand ich am strand
türkei und der hat mir dann gesagt da
war richtig begeistert ja nimmt seine
hände hoch und zeigt mir wie ihr aus der
türkei vom strand daheim in würzburg
seine rolle in hohen oder machen kann
und das ist für mich nicht sinnvoll weil
bin ich im urlaub bindung mit euch
zusammen bin habe ich ganz andere sorgen
du möchtest dir hat irgendwann ja da bin
ich am strand türkei im urlaub
ich möchte mir keine gedanken machen ob
man oben oder unten sind also da ist
dass sie dort nicht fangen
definitiv nicht und am ende haben uns
eigentlich nur für den smart home
entschieden und ich habe den paparazzo
gekriegt weil er nämlich gesagt hat wir
können damit geld sparen genau ob
europas spannung und schwaben ziemlich
die waage und mir war es einfach wichtig
energie zu sparen und zwar es gehe darum
dass nicht unnötig fenster geöffnet
werden dass ich weiß wenn die fenster
offen ist dass ich dass sich die
temperaturen regeln kann also nicht
geregelt dass die temperaturen sind das
haus automatisch und das waren einfach
wichtig auch was für die umwelt zu tun
und natürlich auch niemals sein geld
bald immer gesagt wollte das heißt
sparsamkeit war mir sehr wichtig in der
ganzen geschichte
jetzt denkt ihr wahrscheinlich mensch
sein smartphone das ist ja wirklich nur
was für junge leute für uns und für uns
für euch und um europa kaum
wahrscheinlich gar nicht klar damit aber
es stimmt gar nicht das system ist
wirklich so einfach das wirklich oma opa
auch davon profitieren wir haben es ja
schon in ihrer wohnung eingebaut und es
ist einfach so man oper sparen wirklich
ganz viele handgriffe sie müssen sich
keine gedanken machen über die heizung
über die belüftung über das licht und
haben einfach viel viel mehr zeit für
euch und es ist halt einfach ganz
einfach steuerbar
selbst wenn sie dann diese lichtschalter
haben diese taste an der wand das ist
einfach so einfach zu bedienen die
müssen sich wirklich nur merken licht
beschattung und zum beispiel musik ja
und da können sie echt nichts falsch
machen und werden auf jeden fall nicht
überfordert genau ist schön ist
natürlich in den oman oper mehr zeit für
euch haben dann haben wir mehr zeit um
euch also mit allem zusammen zusammen ja
sagen ja wir lieben uns deshalb sei er
ohne stars nein wirklich so die zwei
selbstreflektion und wir haben uns mal
mit immerhin gerückt am tag und haben
uns überlegt was passiert jeden dafür
ist was machen wir eigentlich jeden tag
was verstehst in unserem leben das heißt
an stehen wir auch heute sind wir
wie viele personen sind wir was sind die
besonderheiten bei uns was sind unsere
vorlieben dh sei es von der temperatur
sei es von von der ganzen technik sei es
darum zb sanierer und er steht nachts
immer auf ihr steht nachts immer auch
und haben wir übrigens als als wir klein
weil man sonst auch immer gemacht und
schönach zimmer auf und dann haben wir
mal angst dass irgendwie stolpert euren
kopf wo anschlägt und deswegen habe man
diese notbeleuchtung reingemacht ist und
manchmal das klo müssen
das war jetzt anders da muss ich aufs
klo dank und dann ist es blaue nicht
angegangen
also dass nacht nicht geschlafen weil
dann sehe ich auch wo ich hin laufen und
vielleicht auch in zukunft einfach so
machen dass er einfach euren eigenen
bett schlafen viel lieber wenn er
eingeschlafen würde ich habe mich beim
platz mehr und außerdem erlanger trifft
mich immer mit den füßen und samira die
chance aber da kann man halt woanders
schlafen und schlafen an ein bett dann
entschlossen wir alle tricks im
egelsbacher kriege ja ich soja hause ist
so wird immer recht hat
also man muss immer schauen was sind die
abläufe im alltag und oftmals ist man
sich den abläufen gar nicht bewusst also
noch macht einfach dinge und ich denke
das haus kann uns da wirklich ganz gut
dabei unterstützen ohne dabei
aufzufallen genau bis zu 50.000
angriffen bis ins handgriff wird ihr
habt mir jetzt vielleicht noch gar nicht
auf dem schirm
hiernach hintern machen müssen ich habe
überlegt mal in unserer alten wohnung
gehen da hatten wir ja unsere zwei
zimmer wohnung und wir hatten diesen
fetten lichtschalter an der wand genau
da alles überall geschaltet
genauer werden überall schalter jeden
rouladen
wir hatten temperaturfühler das heißt
die temperatur einzustellen
der einritt mehr riesenbatterie jetzt
jeden abend sind wir durch die wohnung
gelaufen ich habe erst mal alle
jalousien runter gefahren alle lichter
ausgemacht papa hat sie grundsätzlich
immer wieder angemacht und angelassen
und ich musste dann immer noch alles
kontrollieren hast du noch mal
abschließen
genau und die müssen sich doch wirklich
mal selbst
mit ich mal dahin halten und euch mal
sagt was passiert den ganzen tag über
was für handgriffe macht und er werde
darauf kommen dass es draußen vorhand
gerät jeden tag sind die orange war
angriff oder die wir uns damals spannten
wenn wir nachher mehr zeit für euch aber
jetzt fragt ihr euch bestimmt wie könnt
ihr denn überhaupt zu eurem smartphone
system und wie es so ist wenn man sich
mit einem thema beschäftigt dann ist ja
oft so bei facebook instagram twitter
überall tauchen plötzlich dieses thema
auch wir waren in gruppen in foren auf
messen
man muss einfach mit diesem thema smart
home wirklich beschäftigt an seinen
freundeskreis ungehört genau und dann
als wir dann nach österreich weil er mit
der weltmesse in wels genau auf die
österreicher messer gefahren sind
das war doch er braucht ungefähr zwei
jahren zweieinhalb jahre genau vor
zweieinhalb jahren war das anders
gedacht wir fahren einfach mal bei luxor
vorbei ist ja noch ein anbieter aus
österreich die kommen aus direkt auf dem
weg ja auf dem weg nach nachwelt und wir
haben eine übernachtungsmöglichkeit
gesucht und da man kann ich ja ja und ja
ja müssten achtungs möglichkeit gesucht
und das lustige war einfach die haben da
so ein richtiges show und schon ein haus
wo look schon eingebaut ist und wir
haben gedacht okay die jungs noch mal an
und dann haben wir die einladen auch
schon bekommen doch mal am tag zu
verachten für mich passt der schwabe
auch gut weil die übernachtung kostenlos
mit frühstück sogar und wir sind damit
ich nach nachwelt auf die messe gefahren
und davor sommer in kollerschlag ist es
in der nähe von passau abgebogen und was
mich dabei überrascht hat ich habe
gedacht jetzt fahren wir dahin und dann
ist es bestimmt voll dieses high tech
house aber es war im prinzip ein ganz
normales stinknormal sonst normal des
hauses du bist doch eingelaufen und
dachte so ok besitzt diese smart home
denn es muss halt einfach nicht genau
mal stellt sie hätten wir vor einem
smartphone ähnliche roboter
irgendwelches sprachsteuerung irgendwas
und es lustige waren wir sind nicht
hingegangen und damals hat der johannes
hat mir schon alles gezeigt system war
ein einheimischer hand gezeichnet sagt
hirsch das war ja trainingspause ein
johannes
wir sitzen aus erklär uns mal irgendwas
haben denn ich brauche nichts erklären
ist alles selbst erklären unsere
nachbarn wehren uns dann wir waren damit
augenmaß selber noch dabei genau jeder
hat das auf sein zimmer und dann haben
wir uns im wohnzimmer getroffen am
fernsehen ging dieses stimmungslosen da
mache ich in der küche leichter
plötzlich dieses touchpanel auf der
arbeitsfläche das spiel haben übrigens
auch das ist richtig cool auf der
arbeitsfläche und damit kann man zum
beispiel die ganze nicht zu stellen oder
aber nicht nur wenn das recht das ist
genau gesteuert ist nämlich von alleine
so ist es oder du kannst zum beispiel
dukurs italienisches und plötzlich kommt
aus dem lautsprecher pavarotti musik
kochen ist immer was cooles oder kannst
deine lieblings spotify playlist
abspielen lassen wie du möchtest und das
tolle an dem haus war einfach war alles
selbst erklären du hast nicht nachdenken
müssen des hauses auf dich auf deine auf
deine gegebenheiten reagiert und wir
waren einfach nur geflecht richtig also
wenn man es richtig wohl gefühlt weil
einfach alles so versteht was durchdacht
waren wir super da
und wenn ich mir das gespräch mit dem
arzt erinnern ich mir okay der arzt so
viele sachen erklärt und ich habe im
kopf hat sich für mich biene maja abend
gespielt ich war schon komplett draußen
und jetzt gehen wir einfach raus kein
kleiner erklärten dass irgendetwas und
es passiert und ich muss noch sagen als
wir ins schlafzimmer gegangen sind habe
ich mich zuerst geärgert denn im
schlafzimmer der wahl das bett und auf
der bett rückseite war das badezimmer
aber es waren glaswände und ich habe mir
gedacht nach super metroid bitte
glaswände als wartezimmer
wenn du nämlich nachts auf die toilette
geht und das licht anmacht im
schlafzimmer komplett hell aber so war
es nicht denn wenn du nachts auf die
toilette gegangen bist gehen einfach
dieses nacht nicht genau das war richtig
cool und da waren getestet beirats für
uns gesehen habt ihr zeit gehabt ich
habe kein handy gehabt dass ich
irgendwas gesteuert habe ich habe zum
beispiel einfach bei einem wohnzimmer
die tür aufgemacht und plötzlich den der
rollladen nach oben und waren balkon
also auch nicht sinnhaft im unterricht
nicht ausgesperrt denn da vergibt dann
auch die funktion genau
und da war ich richtig begeistert und du
hast das smarthome erlebt aber es war
nicht sichtbar
und so ist jetzt bei uns daheim jetzt
momentan auch du kommst rein und und
siehst nichts aber es passiert einiges
und das hat uns dann überzeugen
[Musik]
jetzt hatte ich bestimmt warum habt ihr
euch denn überhaupt für lux
unentschieden
es ist halt so ich vergleiche mit dem
küchenmaschinen ich sage ja auch immer
bevor ich meinen ohne küchenmaschine
kaufe bei der es nächstes jahr keine
ersatzteile mehr gibt kauf ich mir
lieber eine wo ich weiß das unternehmen
gibt schon lange die haben auch zehn
jahre später noch die ersatzteile für
meine küchenmaschine ich meine ist eine
investition die macht man einmal und
dann wirklich fürs leben wenn man eine
küchenmaschine kauft und so ist es im
prinzip auch mit dem smartphone system
für mich war zum beispiel auch das thema
ich weiß dass viele smartphones geht mit
sprachsteuerung für mich war der aspekt
natürlich auch ich wollte zum beispiel
eine sprachsteuerung
ich bin jemand der mir dauernd zuhört
wenn ich irgendwas sagen dass dann eine
cloud abspeichert und das vielleicht
nachher und werbezwecke benutzt oder
oder die daten weitergibt
es wollte einfach nicht um zumindest
noch nicht genau und loks und
funktioniert wie intuitiv das ding weiß
was ich was ich haben möchte muss
eingestellt habe und meine daten
informiert das heißt mein smartphone
meine daten und das war mir extrem
wichtig und dann gibt es ja auch noch
das problem manche anbieter die machen
es einfach so dass man wirklich alles
von diesem einen anbieter bekommt und
darf keine fremdprodukte benutzen genau
das ist auch nur schleppend von einem
anbieter nehmen die steuerung von wieder
nehmen du musst dieses ding von nur
anbieter nehmen und es wollte ja einmal
wollen flexibel sein ich würde einen
kompatibel alles mit allem sein ich
wollte zum beispiel mit meinen
küchengeräten kompatibel sein ich würde
mit dem kompatibel sein
ohne jetzt immer auf das teure
zuzugreifen und das war auch wichtig als
eine uhr nach bereit zu haben also eine
flexibilität zu haben
genau dann war auch noch wichtig für
mich dass auch regelmäßig updates
gemacht werden das ist immer ganz ganz
wichtig regelmäßige updates hat das
heißt ein unternehmen zu haben wohl
schon über 85.000 häuser gebaut haben
also gebaut haben mit luxus ausgerüstet
habe das war mir extrem wichtig dass wir
da immer wieder updates bekommt und und
als automatische updates bekommt und
nicht noch irgendwie noch irgendwelche
sicherheitslücken hat und die dann nicht
beseitigt werden es kann eben mal über
einmal vorkommen und ist bissig und
nicht ganz wichtig dass ich das system
versteht weil für mich war immer alles
bis hin zu technisch und ich habe immer
gesagt ist es überhaupt sicher wie kann
das alles wie kann ich sonst einstellen
und ich meine vielleicht habe ich heute
meine gewohnheit und lassen ein
elektriker oder den programmierer das
einstellen morgen oder übermorgen ändert
sich die gewohnheit
und ich will einfach selber die sachen
einstellen können und sagen guck mal
heute habe ich so morgen habe ich so
wenn ich es möchte und muss nicht jedes
mal ein fachmann dazu holen und dann ist
mir auch der support bietet man ruft
kurz einmal ein problem und fragte nach
und sagt hey ich hab lassen dass das
problem können wir weiterhelfen und dann
einen support zu haben ist die
natürliche sprache ist mir ganz ganz
wichtig dass jetzt vielleicht ja das ist
alles schon vorgekommen dass man
irgendwo anruft und man spricht die
sprache nicht und sagte herr schild aus
österreich so weit weg und dabei einfach
das verändert ich wollte keine gimmicks
das heißt ich möchte keine irgendwelche
showelemente haben oder irgendwas ich
möchte real smartphone das heißt ich
sachen die mich mit nicht weiterbringen
ich meine man kann spielereien ein
programm das kann man wirklich aber ich
wollte einfach was ganz ganz normale
sachen die mich weiterbringen mich nicht
aufhalten und vor allem zu viel
information auf meinem handy genau und
es gibt diesen spruch was du mir sitzt
das besitzt auf dich und ich wollte
einfach etwas was wir nicht besitzt
sondern man sich besitzer und das ist ja
und man rauch und ruß und was sie beide
optionen auch gut finde ich möchte schon
hier immer wo sind die probleme der
menschen im alltag und dann finden die
smarte lösungen und die gibt es schon
seit über zehn jahren
das heißt sie haben da wirklich auch
erfahrung in diesem gebiet und bringen
einfach jedes jahr immer mehr
innovationen die bleiben nicht stehen
und schauen einfach was könnte man denn
noch ein bisschen verbessern genau im
hard- und softwarebereich genau was
ändert sich auch stetig also ist auch
die ganzen lebensabschnitte ändern sich
man wird älter man hat andere
bedürfnisse ich meine den letzten 20 30
jahren allein durch smart home ist
soviel passiert mache ja nicht komplett
verändert und da muss man immer gegen
stören also was was passiert und da mal
locker ich bis jetzt immer sehr
innovativ und ich bin mal gespannt was
in den nächsten jahren noch zusätzlich
kommt vielleicht bekommt noch ein
drittes kind oder viertes kind oder so
nicht hätte ich wenn das geld dann
richtig nah und finde es auch wichtig
war schon etwas passiert und hat kann
man einfach nur durch eine kleine
programmierung ändern und das ist das
tolle
neurotische neues tool und 1 können wir
euch mit auf den weg geben falls ihr
später auch mal ein haus bauen wollte
was ist haus wohne ich mach sitzung
einen seid ihr dass die familie dann
bringt er aber dann gibt es auch noch
drei faktoren und zwar erst einmal das
licht erst dann aufnehmen und die
temperatur nicht mal das ganz kurz
erklären
es gibt zwei arten nicht will und zwar
ist es eine atmosphäre nicht und ein
arbeitssieg genau wenn ich in der küche
stehe und koche und backe dann bin ich
echt immer ganz helles licht ich will
die zutaten sehen ich will die
zubereitung sehen aber wenn ich dann
vererben habe und der kuchen aus dem
ofen kommt und wir möchten uns hinsetzen
und stück kuchen essen und kaffee
trinken oder tee trinken
dann wollen wir er seine atmosphäre
nicht genau atmosphäre nicht macht wird
bei der arbeit an ich müde aber sorgt
eine stimme haben wohl für die coole
stimme meinung zum beispiel genau und es
ist das tolle ist einfach wenn das ganze
haus möchte sie coole atmosphäre haben
oder freunde zentrale sein dann wird es
automatisch geschehen
und dafür musste man früher wirklich
immer ganz viele verschiedene knöpfe
drücken ich bin eine alte wohnung und da
haben wir natürlich ständig die knöpfe
drücken müssen die kunden für sauber
machen müssen wir nochmal er ständig mit
euren schokolade hätten daran gegangen
seid und das müssen wir jetzt nicht mehr
lohnt wieder passiert automatisch zum
beispiel wenn der fernseher angeht man
geht das sofort die lichtstimmung
verändert sich oder man kann es eben
manuell auch bedienen ist und jetzt
braucht nicht nur 1000 leuchtmittel es
passiert einfach alles automatisch
ja und dann finde ich was zum klima mit
dazu gehört oder zum wohlfühlen ist
einfach aber ich brauche immer frische
luft das heißt ich habe früher immer die
fenster aufgerissen
papa hat immer mit mir geschimpft weil
er sagt das profil bis das haus sich
wieder auf heißt aber ich kann einfach
nur bei frischer luft schlafen ich krieg
da ihr kennt das ja damit das nicht aber
es soll eine morgens um reinkommt ins
schlafzimmer und jeder hat geatmet oder
ihr warten mit uns im schlafzimmer und
dann vier leute in einem kleinen
schlafzimmer
dann ist einfach schlechte luft und dann
ist meistens morgens die fenster
aufreißt aber das kannst du jetzt
automatisch wenn eine automatische
belüftung drin was auch die temperaturen
alles regelt und das heißt wir müssen
auf ein fenster auf
bis sich einfach im ding wo du mich mal
nachdenken muss wird automatisch
geschehen und dann noch das thema
temperatur
wenn ich morgens ins badezimmer g und
ich bin ja immer die erste die auf steht
dann habe ich es ganz gerne wenn der
fußboden ganz warm ist und wenn ich aus
photoshop com will ich nicht frieren
müssen also habe ich da immer die
heizung hochgedreht samira ich weiß auch
ganz genau dass du das immer gemacht
hast papa hat er mir geschenkt
ich habe die heizung aufgedreht war
wegen einer halben stunde und räumlichen
schon sagen zwischen 7 und 8 uhr oder 7
und 9 uhr im bad und zwischen 7 und 9
nährten wir 24 grad
ja dass die man später dann aber unter
mir seeger morgens kriegt ja auch genau
deswegen ist es am nachmittag und
nachmittags rein aus dann wird es wieder
runtergekühlt haben weil genau recht
viel zu wahren weil du gerade mitten bei
der arbeit bist bei der hausarbeit oder
ihr spielt und geht ins wartezimmer dann
ist echt zu warm also ist es jetzt
automatisch so geregelt ist nichts mehr
verstellen sondern morgens ist schön
warm und kuschelig und am nachmittag ist
ein bisschen kühler
genau dann ist es zum beispiel so wir
haben große fenster im wohnzimmer und
wenn wenn es mal die sonne scheint dann
heizt das haus sicher hoch oder haben
wir hier oben auf dem dach haben die
sensoren und diese sensoren schauen
natürlich etwas den lichteinfall habe
ich die warm ist es was bringt es geben
und regelt automatisch die beschattung
es heißt das wohnzimmer ich sagte
wohnzimmer wir wollen 23 grad haben wahr
ist auch es war ja oder 22 grad
22 grad jetzt kommt große sonnenschutz
richtig heiß die beschattung automatisch
runter und das haus versucht selbigen
ära tour zu regeln und wenn das noch
nicht ausreicht dann wird aus der
fußbodenheizung wird dann eine
klimaanlage sorgt das haus genau das
haus reguliert sich von alleine in den
büros im arbeitszimmer von der mama zum
beispiel aber immer 19 grad und frieden
der alten wohnung war es immer so da
hatten wir einfach im winter unserer
fußbodenheizung aber werden keine
möglichkeit im sommer entgegen zu wirken
das heißt wir haben jetzt alles wir
können im sommer und auch im winter die
temperatur ganz von alleine regeln genau
was wir schon auch ist zum beispiel
manchmal so ist ein büro und die sonne
blendet sich und automatisch per die
beschattung runter und tut sie aber ein
regel und stellt dann die lamellen um
und haben trotzdem noch nicht im haus
steht und
möglich geworden ist ja anfangen und
jungs können sich auf die arbeit
konzentrieren und nicht auf die
bestattung ihres zimmers genau das ist
einfach sachen wohnen nicht mehr
mitdenken stellst du einmal eine
reparatur einmal einstellen welche
welche temperatur in welchem raum zu
welcher zeit dann die ganzen
lichteinstellungen dh was man nicht
möchte ich haben
ab wann soll es geregelt werden das
machst du einmal oder nach liebe liebe
das thema sicherheit war uns ganz
wichtig ist uns ganz wichtig ja stimmt
das ganze ist ja immer wichtig genau ich
mich fast immer auf dem harbour auf ich
habe mama ich hab euch und er auf papa
und da wir haben es ist das thema ist
wenn das haus verlässt hast du oftmals
ein gedanke den herd ausgemacht ist noch
drin ist wo es nicht so ist renault türe
auf und jetzt einfach so da jetzt
einfach aus dem haus masten dreifach
klick alarmanlage verzögert
eingeschaltet und sieht sofort was ist
noch im haus noch offen was ist schon
was ist alles gemacht das heißt du
machst du keine gedanken ans haus
verlassen und es läuft alles uns letztes
jahr hatten das thema zwar nicht hier in
deutschland aber der türkei bei oma hat
ein rohrbruch und zwar ab
leider haben sie es erst zwei wochen
später mitgekriegt ja das war's raf ja
das war richtig das war nicht nur wasser
aber mal die ganze wohnung auch voll und
das haben nicht mehr haben sensoren und
das sonst war wasseraustritt fühlen das
design sorgt und die bekomme sofort
benachrichtigen und dann kann man eben
auch sofort eingreifen oder auch das
thema sicherheit im haushalt wenn der
papa kocht oder backt und doch was auf
dem herd weg ist und gebraucht wirst du
auch sofort benachrichtigt egal in
welchem raum ich bin also normalerweise
ist ja immer so da wo der rauch entsteht
gab es danach auch bilder oder auch in
den nebenräumen
aber man weiß eben nicht wo und da
werden wir sofort benachrichtigung das
heißt in der küche gerade roboter grad
im pfannkuchen wir machen ja und beim
thema wenn man beim thema sicherheit
schon sind nachts ist ja auch so wir
machen unseren schlaf modus und alles
geht in ruhe auch auf das haus das heißt
die lichter fahren runter und dann ist
es auch so wenn dann ein fenster oder
eine tür geöffnet werden würde würde das
auch mitbekommen
genau das heißt bei mir probiert es gar
nicht
ein paar jahren was eine coole
geschichte ist sollten im urlaub das ist
die situation wir sind im urlaub und und
mich interessierten diesem moment dieses
haus und ich kann es eigentlich nur dass
es sicher da steht keiner vom 3
genau und was passiert die rollläden
fahren und automatisch nach oben nach
unten zurück zu verschiedenen
tageszeiten aber zu gehen man nicht aus
das heißt es kommt immer kommt keiner
auf den gedanken dass montag ein haus
ist ja ja wir sind dann diese situation
diese simulationen wie abgespielt werden
kollegin ihren geschichten und das haus
heizt nicht unnötig du kannst einstellen
waren wieder zurück kommst dann fertig
temperatur wieder hoch und solange du
wirst sehen also ich sag ich vom selbst
bisweilen sparen genau wir kommen mit 26
september wieder aus dem urlaub zurück
dann ist am 26 september alles wieder
eingestellt perfekt also einjähriger
sohn eigentlich passt das haus besser
auf die kinder auch alles los kalt ist
komisch wird zweimal war sie alleine
gelassen zwei mal geradeaus würden also
zweimal einmal platzrunde einmal der arm
naja muss mir gedanken machen ja doch
solltest du wir wohnen jetzt schon seit
ein paar monaten im haus am anfang
mussten wir erst mal überlegen wie sind
unsere gewohnheiten welche funktionen
soll es geben und dann muss man das am
anfang einfach alles mal einstellen aber
sobald sie dann eingestellt ist hast du
wirklich keine arbeit mehr damit ich
muss nicht mehr nach meinen jalousien
gucken alles ist automatisch aber ich
kann es trotzdem auch noch manuell
steuern wenn ich das möchte
falls ihr euch mal seien loks von show
anschauen wollt dann wie gesagt einmal
in kollerschlag in österreich oder in
wäschenbeuren in der nähe von stuttgart
da könnt ihr euch die funktionen mal
anschauen
und was mir ganz wichtig ist ich wollte
am anfang ein smartphone hat mich dann
doch dafür entschieden und das
wichtigste ist meine daten und bleiben
in meinem haus ich habe keine gimmicks
ich habe wirklich nur richtig gute
funktionen
ich hoffe euch hat dieses video gefallen
und wenn ihr möchtet dass ich mal so
einen antrag von uns film also wirklich
von morgens bis abends und da so ein
bisschen das smartphone integrieren also
zeige wie viele handgriffe ich spare
dann schreibt einfach mal in die
kommentare
da machen wir mal so einen typischen
sandy alltag bei uns im haus also bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]